obrigado quando tinha 24 anos e meu
irmão a gente resolveu fazer uma fábrica
de meias
a gente queria fazer alguma coisa
diferente ea gente descobriu que na
itália estava fazendo uma máquina
totalmente eletrônica podia fazer uma
meia toda desenhada
a gente ficou encantado com a idéia a
gente foi pra lá ficamos seis meses ele
aprendendo a parte mecânica e eu a parte
eletrônica e nos finais de semana a
gente fazia pesquisa de mercado eo
brasil e as marcas de chegar ao brasil
depois de alguns meses
atravessando 30 dias para 30 dias para
atravessar o atlântico mais 60 dias ea
pressão talvez alfred a
estamos falando de marca precol que
tinha cota de importação que importação
é muito difícil ea gente estava no
galpão estavam superexcitados que vão
receber as máquinas chegaram as máquinas
abriram a gente ia visitar em ajudar as
máquinas erradas
brasília qualquer coisa em vez de ser
uma máquina com diâmetro pequeno que
dava pra fazer linhas infantis cuidaram
de diâmetro maior para fazer minhas
meninas não dava pra lançar uma marca de
6 sigma chamada jovem a linha
aí surgiu a idéia de que o negócio tinha
voltado da cidade que ficou encantado
com a beleza das ilhas só que eu tinha
que criar desenhos como é que eu queria
dizer isso na mulher
comecei a copiar os desenhos nos lençóis
da minha sogra
depois acabei quarto nem souberam tinha
que buscar mais referências
me falaram que tinha uma pessoa que
vendia veículos e tendências de moda
falar com o cara e facial querendo
comprar livros tendências de 6
ele falou pra mim 6 eu tenho experiência
de moda feminina e moda masculina de
moda infantil calçados mais meias
cláudio porque se for fazer 66 são
buracos enfiar o pé bom eu pesava
estudava engenharia junto com o irmão
queria fazer uma fábrica de buracos
eu queria fazer alguma coisa que
emocionar as pessoas significasse algo
para as pessoas que a gente viu que
apesar de um produto para muita gente
pode parecer uma commodity se a gente
trabalhar eles maneira diferente de
pensar de uma maneira diferente a gente
pode fazer muito
diferença e se um pouco do conceito da
porque só que a gente não pára aí a
gente lançou um projeto chamado mesmo te
o que esse projeto
a gente percebeu que a segunda campanha
do agasalho
neco é uma coisa super legal você pega
com a roupa que você usa mais e você dá
pra alguém
normalmente quando você tá pra mim esta
copa que tem um risquinho porque saiu de
moto um pouco desgastada se cansou da
prefeita só sei se pensou que você não
tem problema já aprontei uma roupa que
você usa mas só que meia assim só se
envergonha de down também a gente joga
fora na casa
beijo a 6 peça de roupa que mais esforço
é submetido
jogando seu peso 70 quilos 80 quilos
esfregando com a sola de passa quatro
você não faz isso com o teu jeans uma
jaqueta então a 6 ela realmente
construída e as pessoas jogam fora para
não terminar a gente percebeu que ele
também tinha oportunidade tanto de
reciclar esse material uma gangue do
material teste que vai pro lixo a gente
possa falar outra coisa mas sabe também
fazer uma coisa que engloba a
sustentabilidade ea idéia de que é o
nosso processo produtivo é é a gente já
pega os restos industriais e transformam
cobertores
isso pode fazer isso com toda a
população porque ele não pode usar
nossas lojas para coletar todas as meias
de todo mundo
processar e cobertores que dá pra quem
precisa
esse projeto é mesmo bem
o que faz meia pista em cinco anos ea
gente sempre reciclou as obras nos
processos produtivos no cobertores
doentes com a campanha no ano passado
que a gente contava todas as pessoas
fazerem suas meias velhas para nossas
lojas a gente transforma em cobertores e
doa para quem precisa
a gente ficou encantado com o resultado
o engajamento de toda a população teve
de ajudar o próximo ea gente estava
negociando com toda força pra fazer essa
campanha ainda muito maior para
enfrentar todo o brasil e ajudar a quem
precisa
isso aqui na favela de paraisópolis
entretanto nem cobertores graças a
muitas pessoas que doarem
nós também já está fazendo o maior
sucesso
minha bunda entende ligadas à família
amigos também daquele título é da
empresa geralmente é mais fácil alguém
20h da noite da comunidade
vocês vão ter colocado todo trazendo
para acomodar exatamente essas meias
esses cobertores vão fazer diferença
página na vida das pessoas
sobre essas extremamente carentes a um
carro caiu em uma casa bonita
a nossa meta aqui é trinco deixa a
criança nem ajudar sobreviventes
a gente tem sentido as pessoas a levarem
suas meias têm muitos emfa feita nas
lojas pra gente reciclasse nem lucas do
rio verde
então além de um projeto social que há
entre a mulher sustentável
de pouquinho em pouquinho a gente parece
ter essa sim porque para você chegar no
final da estrada você tem que bater um
meio fácil muito fácil um pouquinho né
então se quiser realmente a diferença
leva suas linhas para qualquer loja
porque e participe da campanha mesmo é
se não houver uma loja porque perto de
você participe compartilhando seguinte
uma pequena nação pode fazer uma grande
ajuda a crescer com 25
participe
bom em 2013 a gente empatou 7 milhões de
pessoas a mensagem de 140 mil views
há sempre inclusive o bombeio a gente
conseguiu gerar coletar mesmo pra fazer
dois mil e 200 cobertores e agora em
2014 a gente quer mais do que dobrar
essa meta a gente vai chegar lá a gente
já tá chegando lá a gente conta com o
apoio de várias celebridades que
voluntariamente estão usando as suas
mídias sociais para divulgar essa
mensagem pra gente conseguir coletar
mais meias ter engajamento super legal
tem um site onde a gente com as notícias
explica mais sobre ela sobre a promoção
onde doar os parceiros da campanha geral
consegue muita coisa nos jornais na
mídia que a gente tá poderão
sensibilizar as pessoas de que é
possível fazer a diferença mesmo de algo
tão sem expressão como uma meia né como
a percepção das pessoas em uma coisa tão
algum importante uma commodity se
consegue fazer a diferença é só uma
questão se procura hoje a gente está
ajudando 21 instituições e acho que a
gente pode fazer muito mais
é uma coisa que está crescendo que pode
ir tomar proporções muito maiores
quanto mais as pessoas divulgar e ajudar
nisso